make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and as
much as I love covering stories like
X-Men and Judgment Day and things like
that a lot of those stories can be a
little bit darker so what I wanted to do
here is I wanted to cover some
Spider-Man stuff because while there are
some crazy things that happen in the
Spider-Man stories Spider-Man is by and
large lighthearted and it's always just
a fun read so this is the official start
of Nick Spencer's run with Spider-Man
Back to Basics this comes off the heels
of Dan slots run which we have finished
we do have that and you'll find a link
to that Series in the description to
that whole playlist what this does here
is it's essentially a kind of Spider-Man
reboot to a degree in the sense that
Peter Parker is just kind of going back
to just being the normal Peter Parker
right he's not like the CEO of Parker
Industries he's not Ultra rich or
anything like that of course the the Run
of Dan slot basically solidifies how it
was that he basically lost everything
but with Peter Parker back to his normal
life of course it's him and it's Randy
Robertson who are trying to find an
apartment together now Randy Robertson
has been around for a very very long
time and he's the son of Robbie
Robertson who's basically the guy that
runs The Daily Bugle now now for those
of you guys who don't know who he is
because Robbie Robertson hasn't really
appeared all that often in the
Spider-Man Mythos um he's kind of that
he at least he was for a long time the
second in command to J Jonah Jameson but
following J John Jameson's seeming
departure now uh it's basically Robbie
Robertson who runs the show and so with
Randy and Peter being friends for a long
time it's them kind of doing their thing
but as they're hunting around for a new
apartment suddenly they're met by the
arrival of like Boomerang and Electro at
least the new Electro Francine and then
like Rhino and big wheel and it's small
time right these are not great big huge
things and while it is easy to look at
that and kind of consider it to be silly
it's sort of a Hallmark of the
Spider-Man comics that is one of these
situations where you get characters you
get villains that aren't like massive
players in the realm of of comic books
but it's always just kind of fun to see
them and they are by all standards the
measurement the new sinister six so to
speak now of course Peter ends up taking
off because of course he tells Randy
like yeah I gotta take pictures for The
Daily Bugle of course him being
Spider-Man he leaps into action and of
course it's one of these cool things
because he's able to overpower these
guys pretty readily but it's also a fun
little moment here for years and years
and years of Marvel Comics The reason
why I say this for years in Marvel
Comics it was one of these things where
we didn't really know why Peter cracked
jokes outside of the fact that it was
just kind of the lighthearted nature of
his Comics the reason why Peter tells
jokes is because it tricks his enemies
into thinking he's not taking them
seriously and because they don't think
he's taking them seriously they get
irritated they get angry and then their
ability to focus begins to diminish and
so it makes it easier to defeat them now
it's also the other part of it that it
keeps the Spider-Man stories
entertaining but one of the things that
Peter does when he hits on this is he is
when rhinos says like he can't take all
of us at once Peter cracks a joke and
it's kind of like I'm not really taking
you guys out seriously but in reality he
is right and he's like rhinos right like
there's just too many of them I have to
basically find a way to thin these
numbers even if it only offers a
momentary distraction and so of course
he does and he's able to basically
defeat all these guys only for the
Kingpin Wilson Fisk to show up now the
Kingpin has traditionally been a villain
in Marvel Comics and he still is but one
of the things that we had talked about
in recent years is that after the events
of secret Empire when Captain America
had basically had his history modified
using a Cosmic Cube to turn him into a
villain that during that storyline you
basically had the city of New York that
was encased in dark force energy what it
did is it basically trapped everybody in
the city of New York all the different
Heroes who were there it removed them
from being a threat to Captain America
but you had Kingpin who was actually
traveling around and keeping people safe
from street level criminals because the
other Heroes who were there were trying
to do things like ensure that they could
try to find a way to escape but they
weren't really focusing on the little
guy Kingpin however was doing that and
so because people in the city of New
York started to see him as a champion of
the people when everything went back to
normal at the end of secret Empire
Wilson Fisk ran for mayor and won and
that's how he ended up having the
position he's in now now course this
does take place before the events of
Devil's Reign just so you guys know so
Devil's Reign hasn't really happened yet
but his Kingpin basically finding ways
to expand his criminal influence using
the legal route to do it right using his
position as a as the mayor to pull that
off and of course we saw that come to
fruition with the devil's Reign
storyline for those of you guys who are
curious but the thing about this is that
Boomerang just takes off right they have
all these little boomerangs that belong
to him and stuff like that he's like
well you guys are forgetting one and
they're like What's that he's like the
jettering and they're like he just takes
off and he leads the other criminals to
their fate and Peter's like yep that's
kind of what Boomerang does guys he'll
leave you hanging like he'll literally
bail on you
and so once Peter gets back to Randy
Randy ended up finding a three-bedroom
apartment that the two of them could
rent which isn't a pretty great location
right it's got a skylight I mean it's
nice it's a really really nice apartment
or at least as nice as they can get but
when the questions asked by Peter well
who in the hell is going to be renting
the third room we end up finding out
that it's actually Boomerang so Peter's
basically sharing an apartment with a
Criminal
now this is not an overly important part
of this story but it's not huge here I
just wanted to cover this because I
think that it basically sets the stage
for the look and the feel of the
Spider-Man stories of course things will
get serious here in a little bit but of
course basically Boomerang is a crappy
roommate right the guy just leaves stuff
all over the place he's lazy he tells a
story about about him basically being
caught by Peter but he flips the script
in terms of him being caught by
Spider-Man and saying like well you know
I'm I'm the one that got him you know
and you know Spider-Man admires me and
you know all those different things and
of course making it look like he's more
of a hero than he is but while all this
is going on one of the things to know is
the stories kind of told in hindsight to
a degree because at the moment Peter is
alongside the Avengers facing off
against all these aliens that just kind
of seem to keep coming and coming and
coming right showing up over and over
and over again but one of the big things
that also happens here because that
alien invasion will be important here in
a second one of the big things that
happens here is that Peter is basically
brought before a kind of a kind of ESU
event right brand new day which is kind
of a play on the Spider-Man Brand New
Day idea but what they do is they're
basically releasing a piece of software
that has the ability to scan the
documents of anybody who submits work
and then determine whether or not it is
a fraudulent work right whether or not
they had committed plagiarism and so
what ends up happening is the works of
Peter Parker are brought before the
piece of software and Peter Parker being
considered one of the most celebrated
students his work is analyzed and it
turns out to be fraudulent now here's
the reason why this happens and it's a
great throwback right it was written by
Otto Octavius when he was The Superior
Spider-Man when Dr Octopus had taken
over the body and the mind of Peter
Parker and then operated as Spider-Man
because Otto Octavius was quote unquote
technically the one who wrote this it's
technically not Peter Parker's work
which means Peter Parker has now been
found guilty of plagiarism it's a cool
thing because one of the things to know
while this kind of seems to come out of
nowhere I mean literally he gets canned
from his job all that kind of stuff
right he's talking to Mary Jane Watson
trying to figure out what he's gonna do
he's being chastised by Aunt May which
is really the worst Stone right where
she's one of those things where she's
like I'm not angry I'm just disappointed
do you know what I mean like when a
parent does that you're just like damn
it just it just crushes your soul you
know the reason why this is such a funny
thing here is because it's the Parker
look for those of you guys who are not
familiar with Spider-Man there was a
time towards the end of Dan slots run
going into like Parker Industries it's
one of the reasons why people didn't
really people didn't seem to latch onto
that story too much where Peter was like
a billionaire and everything was going
great in his life that historically
speaking Peter has the Parker luck so
just when things are going great
something's gonna happen that's gonna
screw it all up right sometimes it's a
mistake that Peter makes sometimes it's
because just a villain shows up and it
keeps him or it forces him to miss a
date with Mary Jane Watson it's just any
number of things right he just can't
quite seem to get things to go his way
all the time and so it's a really great
way to kind of hit into that right to
say like the things that have happened
with Peter over the course of his life
even if they weren't necessarily his
fault or coming back to haunt him now
and so what ends up happening is kind of
jumping back to this major fight that's
going on here right with all these
aliens and stuff Peter takes his risk
right he makes this this kind of gamble
where he leaps to the source of where
these aliens seem to be coming from and
when he gets there he literally finds
just a giant Dome and inside it's
Mysterio this whole thing is just a ruse
by Quentin Beck it's a trick and it's
written in like the most classic
Spider-Man way ever right like 1960s
1970s Spider-Man where he's like these
fools believe that they are under attack
from another world little do they know
it is I Mysterio who has engineered
their greatest defeat it's designed to
be a little hokey and kind of a
throwback to the old school Spider-Man
stories and so of course you basically
end up having Quentin Beck who's
defeated and the Avengers realize it was
all just basically an illusion and they
all kind of go back to doing their thing
but the truth about this and this is
where the story really begins to get
interesting is you have Peter who is
basically talking to Mary Jane Watson
and saying look like I almost died
tonight right and I I get that that
happens a lot right more than I would be
willing to admit and the truth is if I'm
being honest nothing is felt right for a
long time and I think I know why we've
been through so much together we
survived it so much together and I know
that on my end at least if you hadn't
been there I would not have survived it
it's because of you thinking about you
having a life with you that it keeps me
going and it makes it easier for me to
survive these just you know almost life
destructive things these circumstances
that I end up in only for us to find out
that with him talking to Mary Jane
Watson the two of them basically end up
making out now this is a huge deal when
it comes to to the Spider-Man Mythos and
the reason why is because ever since the
events of Spider-Man one more day the
idea of Peter Parker and Mary Jane
Watson getting back together has always
been something that Marvel's sort of
been a little Cloak and Dagger about
right like will they won't they and
different writers including Dan slot
have kind of teased it like will they
get back together and it's just enough
of a tease to make you believe they will
but they ultimately never did this seems
to be the story where they're getting
back together again so for traditional
Spider-Man fans it's the long-awaited
reunion right the long long-awaited
reinstatement of a relationship that in
their eyes never really should have
known ended in the first place now the
kicker to all this and this is where we
really start to get into the meat and
potatoes of this is where Mysterio is
basically being put on trial for his
actions and then you essentially have
Janice Lincoln who shows up now Janice
Lincoln is not a major player here she's
the daughter of Tombstone just kind of a
quick little explanation Alonzo Lincoln
was just a guy who who I mean he's a
colonel he's no he's by no means a major
player but he's still a criminal
nonetheless his daughter Janice was
enamored with his criminal life always
wanted to become a part of that life so
when the opportunity presented itself
she became the beatle which again is a
small time villain and then basically
became a criminal in her own right for
reasons that we'll find out here in a
second with her having a history in law
and having been involved in law for
quite some time she shows up here to
initially represent Quentin Beck who
basically shoots it down and of course
she presents the idea that no no I'm
representing Clinton back and he pleads
not guilty for reasons of insanity but
where he shoots that down and says no
that's ridiculous suddenly she starts
puking up all these insects Rats start
appearing out of nowhere the entire room
begins to crumble and fall apart and
then a disembodied voice comes out of
nowhere and is just like quentinquent
and Quentin like you should know better
than to try to run away from me man like
you should know you can't run from me
that way only for us to find out that
it's just a person who's there right now
this being does actually have a name
right their name is Kindred and we'll
learn about them over the course of this
run if you want to you can spoil it for
yourself but I would I would highly
advise you don't do that because the the
progress to learning about this
character is phenomenal right it's just
one of the best parts of the Spider-Man
run that Nick Spencer had wrote but
basically it's one of these things where
there seems to have been an agreement
that was worked out between Kindred and
and Mysterio where Kindred would give
Mysterio the means by which he could
participate in his part of the plan that
Kindred had set up which was to which we
don't really know what it is to be
honestly not at this moment anyway but
that Mysterio had basically defected
from that plan when he blew off Janice
Lincoln now the thing about this is
Kinder's response is like I like if if I
didn't really think you could be a part
of this plan if you didn't matter to me
you'd be dead I never would have gotten
a hold of Janice and I never would have
sent her over to you in order to ensure
that you could basically get off for
your crimes but you turned down my offer
right you turned down this whole thing
and so quite literally Quentin Beck is
begging for his life which indicates
that Kindred have the ability to kill
this guy now there are some statements
that are made which is like I brought
you back from hell I can send you back
different things along those lines which
gives us some small Clues into who
Kindred is but playing this for what it
is and just kind of rolling with it as a
new story right just kind of keeping
that suspension of disbelief you know
not really spoiling anything it really
presents a lot of mystery there and so
one of the crazy things that happens is
that where Kindred says okay fine like I
will give you another chance you had
better not fail me that Quentin back
begging for his life is all basically
shown to be an Illusion by Kindred none
of it seems to have actually happened in
terms of a real and tangible life but
what it does is it gives the perception
that Quentin Beck is really going insane
I mean literally he's acted out all of
this in front of the court they really
think he's crazy and even Janice doesn't
seem to know what's going on because
she's like damn that was one hell of a
show you know and so he ultimately
accepts her offer but that's where you
kind of get the explanation something
much bigger is going on here now
following this things kind of move
relatively quickly right for example
Peter Parker had him been busted for
plagiarism has to retake the class that
he had initially plagiarized of course
his uh his instructor is basically the
lizard right so that's a really cool
thing you get doc Connors who basically
comes back but what doc Connors is
working on as part of his own version of
what's really Horizon Labs right just
some of the smartest people just
essentially working together albeit in a
classroom setting is they're working on
the genome right and in fact they're
actually working on a genome isolation
unit kind of an isotope generator but
what this does is it creates a really
interesting situation where seemingly
out of nowhere Taskmaster and black ants
show up for the purpose of like stealing
this thing right like literally
snatching it up and running off with it
right so this isotope accelerator we
don't know exactly what it will do but
essentially it'll modify the human
genome a great big huge fight breaks out
between all of them of course Peter
Parker creates a distraction by kind of
detonating these fumes all over the
place which allows him to become
Spider-Man he faces off against these
guys he basically fights them defeats
him and is ultimately blasted by the
device when it's inadvertently activated
and when that happens he actually ends
up separating Peter Parker from
Spider-Man so they're basically two
separate people and things get really
cool here because what ends up happening
is that while Peter Parker sort of
enjoys his life and Spider-Man goes out
and fights crime there is a little bit
of a discussion there between the two of
them right like how exactly do we cope
with this how do we deal with this right
I mean there's you know how does this
life work right I mean you are
Spider-Man I am Peter Parker so do you
just be Spider-Man and I just live the
life of Peter Parker and you just kind
of go forward from there but the other
part of this is that they are identical
right so they think exactly the same way
what one does the other would do and so
what it does is it allows Peter Parker
to enjoy his own life with himself with
Mary Jane Watson and his friends and so
on and it allows Spider-Man to go
forward and basically be a superhero in
New York it's really what Peter Parker
always wanted in a lot of different ways
the big problem with this comes to a
head when you see the re-emergence of
the try Sentinel now the tricentennial
is old school right it's an old school
thing so this goes all the way back to
the days of Life project wide awake and
acts of Vengeance and all that kind of
stuff in effect what you had here is a
guy named Sebastian Shaw who you've
heard of if we're covering the X-Men
Comics he has something called Shaw
Industries Sebastian Shaw was part of a
group called The hellfire club which
basically existed to influence the world
and to make sure that their schemes or
desires always came to fruition but
above all else to make sure they always
come out on top right they're like
they're never really persecuted or
anything along those lines and so
Sebastian Shaw being a part of the
hellfire club with that being its
Charter had basically helped the federal
government with project Wide Awake by
essentially creating three uh prototype
Sentinels that would be the Forerunner
for what would eventually become Nimrod
but during Loki's acts of engine story
line when Loki United all the different
villains together to fight the differing
Heroes that Loki had merged the three
Sentinels together and then in turn
created the tri Sentinel which was just
following the Ryman region of Loki which
was to destroy superheroes ultimately
Spider-Man when he had the power of
Captain Universe defeated Tri Sentinel
and that was seemingly the end of that
but for a reason that hasn't necessarily
been explained the tri Sentinel has
returned now of course Spider-Man shows
up here and is basically able to attack
the tri Sentinel and basically start to
bring it down but that's when Peter
starts to notice huge differences that
where Spider-Man had been going forward
and fighting guys like Adrian tombs
right vulture and then just beating him
up and in this instance in the with a
tri Sentinel what it does is it shows
that Spider-Man doesn't really seem to
have any regard for collateral damage
all it really cares about is just
defeating guys being Reckless different
things along those lines it creates
problems and in fact when he goes to
visit doc Connors one of the things
Connor says is yes I mean Peter doesn't
say like oh my God this is what seems to
be happening but Kurt Connor talking to
him about these are the kind of issues
that we run into here that the further
these two these two rats for example
that were experimented on using this
this accelerator the further they are
away from each other or the longer
they're away from each other kind of
separated basically the more decrease
their mental faculties become they
basically become Dumber right they get
dumber and dumber and dumber as time
goes on until they reach whatever
conclusion this happens to be which they
don't really know what it is but the
important thing here is that it's
illustrating that Peter himself will
experience diminished intelligence
alongside Spider-Man and the
consequences could be even more worse
than that the other part of this is we
basically end up switching over to the
person that is the the logic behind why
this try Sentinel is attacking which is
Mendel's strong now Mendel's strong
again this is this is why the story is
called Back to Basics because it's
essentially Nick Spencer giving us a
tour of these classic Spider-Man
villains that honestly we hadn't really
seen or heard from for quite some time
Mendel's Strom was initially one half of
Osborne Industries right that he and and
Norman osw one had worked together for
quite some time and in fact mendelstrom
was the one who was responsible for the
creation of the goblin serum that
ultimately Norman Osborne took and then
became the Green Goblin but the way that
things initially played out is that
essentially Norman Osborne had forced
mendelstrom out of Osborne Industries
now that'll basically be a retold origin
or a retold story involving his
character which we'll find out later on
in the Spider-Man run of Nick Spencer
himself the thing about this though is
that because he had all he had basically
been forced out that mendelstrom had
always harbored a vendetta against
Norman Osborne he'd always hated him and
he always wanted to get his revenge on
Norman but with Norman basically being
out of the picture now mendelstrom saw
this as being his time but yet again
he's running into frustration by
Spider-Man who's not only seized control
of the try Sentinel but actually
re-spray painted his face to make it
look like Spider-Man which is kind of
cool when you think about it
it's pretty awesome when you when you
look at that but that's kind of the
issue that's being ran into here is that
what you're seeing is that Peter Parker
is kind of the conscience of Spider-Man
and that was Spider-Man operating
without the conscience of Peter Parker
that Spider-Man is more Reckless he
doesn't really care about the collateral
damage or the people that are hurt it's
more about just having fun the other
part of this is that you end up having
Peter who goes back and visits Kurt
Connors only to find out that both rats
have died and that's the consequence
here that as long as Peter Parker and
Spider-Man as long as they stay apart
and the longer they stay apart they will
inevitably die and so things will just
get progressively worse right they will
lose their mental faculties that
Spider-Man will become progressively
Reckless right that he'll lead his
actions will lead to the deaths of more
and more people and it'll essentially
you know ultimately end and the two of
them die and so in order to prevent the
massive loss of life that Spider-Man
could inflict as well as just ensuring
his own Survival the mission of peer is
to grab Spider-Man and to force them to
base basically reunite uh using the
using the genome accelerator and then
bringing it back into a singular person
but the other part of this is that from
mendelstrom he's played by his failure
at the hands of Spider-Man and sees
himself as yet a person who's just
continued to fail along this task of
trying to basically you know reinsert
himself back to Glory or however it is
that you want to describe it the issue
here is that he's basically visited by
Kindred and what Kindred does is that
while Kindred does not necessarily
appear per se Kindred basically makes a
deal with uh mendelstrom that if
mendelstrom will work for him and will
ensure his campaign right destroying
Spider-Man so on and so forth that he
will give mendelstrom an army of try
Sentinels which he does right
mendelstrom is granted all these try
Sentinels one just to give you guys
perspective one was difficult for
Spider-Man to defeat an army of them is
damn near impossible and so what ends up
happening is you basically pick up with
mendelstrom launching a campaign against
the city of New York basically trying to
destroy Peter Parker and basically
everybody there the problem with the
deal that mendelstrom made is he was so
obsessed with basically gaining the try
Sentinels and achieving his goal of
basically overcoming or really kind of
elevating himself to a higher state he
never considered the full totality of
the deal that he was making which is his
life his life is now forfeit and so he's
literally destroyed by the forces of
Kindred now this will become an
important factor later on down the line
in fact it'll become stupendously
important so while it seems to come out
of nowhere and doesn't seem to serve a
purpose I do want you to keep it in the
back of your mind as we get further and
further into Nick Spencer's run but
beyond that you have Peter and you have
Spider-Man who are literally fleeing for
their lives from this tricycle is
hunting them down but the Sentinel
launches an attack but in the attack
Peter Parker is severely injured and
Spider-Man realizing the significance of
this and Peter Parker talking to him
saying that hey at least I got to go out
you know trying to save people one last
time and and so on and so forth and
basically kind of offering himself up is
not really a martyr but somebody who is
quote unquote made the ultimate
sacrifice that what it does is it leads
to Spider-Man basically seeing like okay
maybe there is some kind of a kind of a
thing here and Peter Parker tries to
push on that right tries to nudge that
and he says but maybe this is what you
needed to have happen to finally
understand that with great power there
must also come great responsibility that
these things can be prevented and we can
prevent things like this from happening
in the future if we reunite if we come
back together and the response of
Spider-Man is yeah no no I'm good man
I'm doing my thing I'm Gonna Keep on
having fun doing my thing and Peter's
like well it was worth it so like
because he has him in position he
basically fires off the uh the the
machine which basically was designed
like located in this exact spot Peter
had essentially LED Spider-Man here
basically in order to ensure this
happened it basically fires on the two
of them and then reunites them back
together again which of course restores
Peter Parker's conscience back to the
body of Spider-Man and the two of them
kind of go forward and do their thing
right they ultimately at least try to
fight one of the tri Sentinels but it
really doesn't seem to work and the
other Tri Sentinels basically end up
flying back into mendelstrom and then of
course the entire building explodes once
Peter Parker gets to mendelstrom and
realizes something else was going on
here that somebody had done this to
mendelstrom that there's something
seemingly taking place that Peter is not
fully aware of but it's one of those
cool things because what you end up
having is you kind of switch back to
task master and you switch back to black
ant and you end up finding out that them
basically stealing that isotope
generator right that that whole that
whole Rouge there it was never actually
about without stealing that device that
was never the point here it was never
really to do that they had no intention
of actually stealing it them being there
and initiating that entire conflict that
was done at the behest of Kindred that
Kindred plays a very particular game and
so what Kindred seems to have been doing
is orchestrating things in such a way to
where Peter Parker was temporarily
broken and then essentially reinstated
what the purpose of that is we'll see
you know at a future point in time but
again like it's the the basis behind
this first story is to establish that
kindred's the one basically behind the
scenes running the show it's a big time
deal it's a pretty cool situation and so
what we're going to do in the next one
in the next video that we do we're
actually going to pick up with Craven
the hunter which is going to be a really
really cool story arc and one that I'm
exceedingly excited about but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace